Donald Trump is going to be impeached again. There
is every indication of that. And this is the right
move. And it is actually it has to happen. And I'm
going to to make that case for you today, because,
number one, when impeachment is
appropriate, you don't calculate,
you do it. It is the duty of Congress to do it.
And waiting even one more day is another day. That
could be an absolute and total disaster. So the
latest news from The New York Times this morning
is that the House of Representatives, controlled
by Democrats, is moving to force Donald Trump out.
And it's sort of a if you don't, then we will
scenario. Speaker of the House Nancy Pelosi
says the House is going to formally call on Vice
President Mike Pence to invoke the 25th Amendment
and strip Trump of his power. If they do not,
then the House is going to move to impeach Donald
Trump. There is every indication they have the
votes. There is every indication it could happen
as soon as tomorrow or Wednesday. Now, on the 25th
Amendment, the 25th Amendment is this mechanism
by which the president, along with a
majority of I'm sorry, the vice president,
along with a majority of the president's cabinet,
can decide if the president is unfit to serve,
that they can remove the president. The president
has the opportunity to veto or reject that. And
in that case, it goes back to the House and
Senate. And I now I'm blanking. I believe you
need two thirds of the House and Senate to vote
to override the decision of the president. So
even if they. Pursued it, it's quite possible
that it would not succeed at removing Trump
from every report we've gotten so far, Mike Pence
does not have any interest in moving forward on
25th Amendment. And assuming that that is the
case, we have already seen drafted articles of
impeachment again for Donald Trump, which would
make him the second the first president ever to
be impeached for a second time. Expectations are
that debate in the House would be relatively short
and concise and that Donald Trump within 48
hours, very well could find himself impeached.
Once again, the plan is that today and maybe by
the time you've heard this, it will already have
happened. The House is going to move forward with
a resolution calling on Pence to invoke the 25th.
And in all likelihood, that will go nowhere. And
then tomorrow we would be looking at impeachment.
Now, there's a big debate now and we're going
to get into some of the details of it later on.
What if this is divisive and it's so funny to
hear these same Republicans who were involved
in the Hangu Mike Pence chance now saying, no,
we we can't divide the country like this. The
same Republican lawmakers now who for two months
fomented and perpetuated these ridiculous notions
that the election was stolen from Donald Trump
through conspiracies that involved everything
from replacement parts and voting machines
to Hugo Chavez and some guy named Eric Kumah.
They are saying it would be divisive to impeach
Donald Trump. There are others who are saying
the removal or impeachment of Donald Trump at
this late stage would unnecessarily inflame the
same riotous mob that we saw stormed the Capitol
last week. My view on this, you all know that
I essentially am always thinking pragmatically
and in terms of principles and that I am always
open to considering the practical impact of
something beyond just what it means in principle.
Impeachments of presidents are such a serious
thing. And when we think about whether a president
should be impeached, there is only one question
that we ask. Did the president do something
worthy of impeachment? And if the answer is yes,
you don't say, well, there's only 10 days left.
You don't say, well, some of the right wingers
might get mad. It is the responsibility of the
Congress to impeach when something impeachable
has taken place, even many Republican defenders
of Donald Trump will play these clips for you
later. Chris Christie, Senator Pat Toomey,
Lisa Murkowski, even Republicans now are saying
this is a man that needs to be removed. And so
in this case, we say we deal with the
consequences. If it is appropriate to
impeach based on the facts, then we do it.
And that's exactly what needs to happen. So later
today, we will be having a live stream as these
deliberations get underway. We are going to be
covering it all of this week. That is my position
on impeachment. It's it's a it's a responsibility.
You don't say, well, what might the impact be if
something impeachable has been done? You impeach.
Let me know if you disagree with me. I'm on
Twitter at David Pakman. And we're going to have
a much broader conversation about this coming up.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.